after 42 years full of questions a
family now has closure metro police
announcing they have solved the cold
case homicide involving kim bryant from
1979. joe mohler joins us live outside
of metro police headquarters with how it
was solved joe
metro says the new dna testing method
helped them figure this out they say
johnny blake preston is responsible for
the murder of kim bryant who was killed
when she was just 16 years old
since 1979 many have wondered who killed
kim bryant the lvmpd homicide section
investigated this case for years the
western high school student was
kidnapped raped and murdered her body
was found in the desert the case went
cold as nobody was ever connected to the
crime until now based on sperm recovered
from the body of kim bryant at autopsy
revealed that johnny blake peterson was
the person who kidnapped sexually
assaulted and murdered kim bryant
peterson was 19 at the time and briefly
went to western as well this was solved
after a donation from philanthropist
justin wu condolences to kim's family we
hope that we provided a little bit of
closure for you the donation helped pay
for a newer dna testing method the lab
was author inc out of texas otherum is
able to provide leads that lead to the
salt dr kristen middleman says they take
a deeper look at dna samples they then
look into a genealogical database used
for law enforcement to link the samples
to family members or family trees that
lead is given to investigators in this
case peterson's family we can take those
cases that have failed all those other
methods and we can still solve them
there's still hope for these families
nobody should have to wait 42 years to
find out who murdered their child
now back out here live it is not known
if brian and peterson knew each other at
the time of the murder there will be no
trial because peterson did die back in
1993 now this is the second case that
has been solved like this here in las
vegas middlemen does say that more cases
will be solved here in the very near
future reporting live outside of metro
headquarters this evening joe mohler
live local now